the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we're we're through with techniques
of integration which is really the most
technical thing that we're going to be
doing and now we're just clearing up a
few loose ends about calculus and the
one that we're going to talk about today
will allow us to deal with infinity and
it's what's known as l'hopital's rule
so here's l'hopital's rule that's what
we're going to do today l'hopital's rule
is also known as l'hopital's rule that's
the same name since the circumflex is
what you put in french to to omit the s
so it's the same thing it's still
pronounced l'hopital even if it's got an
S in it alright so that's the first
thing you need to know about it and what
this method does is it's a convenient
way to calculate limits including some
new ones so it'll be convenient for the
old ones so there are going to be some
new ones and as an example you can
calculate X log X as X goes to infinity
you could whoops that's not a very
interesting one let's try X goes to zero
from the positive side and you can
calculate for example X e to the minus X
as X goes to infinity and well maybe
maybe I should
include a few others maybe something
like log X over X as X goes to infinity
so these are some examples of things
which in fact if you plug into your
calculator you can see what's happening
with these but if you want to understand
them systematically it's much better to
have this tool of l'hopital's rule and
certainly there isn't a proof just based
on a calculation in a calculator all
right so now here's the idea I'll
illustrate the idea first with an
example and then we'll make it
systematic and then we're going to
generalize that will make it much more
so when it when it includes these new
limits there are some little pieces of
trickiness that you have to understand
so let's just take an example that you
could have done in the very first unit
of this class the limit as X goes to 1
of X to the 10th minus 1 divided by x
squared minus 1 all right so that's a
limit that we could have handled and the
thing that's interesting I mean this is
if you if you like this is in this
category that we mentioned at the
beginning of the course of interesting
limits what's interesting about it is
that if you do this silly thing which is
just plug in x equals 1 you're going to
get at x equals 1 you're going to get 0
over 0 and that's what we call an
indeterminate form it's just unclear
what it is from that plugging in you
just can't get it now on the other hand
there's a trick for doing this and this
is the trick that we did at the
beginning of the class and the idea is I
can divide in the numerator and
denominator by X minus 1 okay so this
limit is unchanged if I try to cancel
the the hidden factor X minus 1 in the
numerator and denominator now we can
actually carry out
these ratios of polynomials and
calculate them by long division in
algebra that's very very long we want to
do this with calculus and we already
have we already know that this ratio is
what's called a difference quotient and
then in the limit it tends to the
derivative of this function so the idea
is that this is actually equal to in the
limit let's just study one piece of it
so if I have a function f of X which is
X to the 10th minus 1 and the value at 1
happens to be equal to zero then this
expression that we have which is in
Disguise this this is in disguise the
difference quotient alright tends to as
X goes to one the derivative which is f
prime of 1 that's what it is so we know
what the numerator goes to and similarly
we'll know what the denominator goes to
but what is that well f prime of X is
equal to ten X to the ninth power so we
know what the answer is in the numerator
it's 10 X to the ninth in the
denominator it's going to be 2x that's
the derivative of x squared minus 1 and
then we're going to have to evaluate
that at x equals 1 and so it's going to
be ten halves which is five all right so
the answer is five and it's pretty easy
to get from our techniques and knowledge
of derivatives using this rather clever
algebraic trick this business of
dividing by X minus one what I want to
do now is just carry this method out
systematically and that's going to give
us the approach to what's known as
l'hopital's rule what I'm a nub jecht
for today so here's the idea suppose we
are considering in general a limit as X
goes to some number a of f of X divided
by G of X and suppose it's the bad case
where we can't decide
right so it's indeterminate F of a is
equal to G of a is equal to zero so it
would be zero over zero now we're just
going to do exactly the same thing we
did over here namely we're going to
divide a numerator and denominator and
we're going to repeat that argument so
we have here f of X divided by X minus a
and G of X divided by G X minus a also
alright I've haven't changed anything
yet and now I'm going to write it in
this suggestive form namely I'm going to
take separately the limit in the
numerator in the denominator and I'm
going to make one more shift so I'm
going to take the limit as X goes to a
in the numerator but I'm going to write
it as f of X minus F of a divided by X
minus a so that's the way I'm going to
write the numerator and I've got to draw
a much longer line here so why am I
allowed to do that that's because f of a
is 0 so I didn't change this numerator
of the numerator and E by subtracting
and F of a is equal to zero and I'll do
the same thing in the denominator again
G of a is zero so this is OK and lo and
behold I know what these limits are this
is f prime of a divided by G prime so
that's it that's the technique and this
evaluates the limit and it's not so
difficult the formula is pretty straight
forward here and it works provided that
G prime of a is not zero yeah question
and more of an intuitive sense that the
limits derivatives really they're more
intuitive wait up
the question is is there a more
intuitive way of understanding this this
procedure and I think the the only I
can't the answer the short answer is
that there are other similar ways I
don't consider them to be more intuitive
I will be mentioning one of them which
is the idea of linearization which goes
back to what we did in unit 2 if that if
that's I mean I think it's very
important to understand all of these
more or less at once but I don't I
wouldn't claim that any of these methods
is more intuitive one than the other all
right but basically what's happening is
we're looking at the linear
approximation to F at a and the linear
approximation to G a day that's what
underlies this all right so now I get to
formulate for you l'hopital's rule at
least in the what's cut what I would
call the easy version or if you like
version one so here's the l'hopital's
rule a version it's not going to be
quite the same as what we just did it's
going to be much much better and more
useful alright and what it's going to
take care of is this problem that the
denominator is not 0 all right so now
here's what we're going to do we're
going to say that it turns out that the
limit as X goes to a of f of X divided
by G of X is equal to the limit as X
goes to a of f prime of X divided by G
prime of X now that looks practically
the same as what we said before I have
to make sure that I that you understand
when it works so works provided this is
one of these undefined expressions in
other words f of a is equal to G of a
is equal to zero so we're having we have
a zero over zero expression
indeterminate and also we need one more
assumption and the right hand side the
right hand limit limit exists all right
now this is practically the same thing
as what I said over here namely I took
the the ratio of these functions X to
the tenth minus one and x squared minus
one
I took their derivatives which is what I
did right here right
I just differentiated them I took the
ratio this is way easier than the
quotient rule and is nothing like the
quotient rule alright don't think
quotient rule don't think quotient rule
all right so we differentiate the
numerator and denominator separately and
then I take the limit as X goes to one
and I get five all right so that's what
I'm claiming over here I take these
functions I replace them with this ratio
of derivatives and then I take the limit
instead over here and it turned out that
the functions got much simpler when I
differentiated them I started with this
messy object and I got this much easier
object that I could easily evaluate
alright so that's the big game that's
happening here it works if this if this
limit makes sense and this limit exists
now notice I didn't claim that G that
the denominator had to be nonzero so
that's what's going to help us a little
bit in a few examples well so let me
give you a couple examples and then
we'll go further this is only version
one but first we have to understand how
this one works
so here's another example take the limit
as X goes to zero of sine 5x divided by
sine 2x this is another kind of example
of a limit that we discussed in in the
first part of the course unfortunately
now we're reviewing stuff so this should
reinforce what you did there this will
be an easier way of thinking about it
so by l'hopital's rule so here's the the
step we're going to take one of these
steps this is the limit as X goes to one
of the derivatives here so that's 5
cosine 5 X divided by 2 cosine 2 X thank
you
it was the limit was 1 over there but
now it's zero a is zero in this case
right this is the number a thank you all
right so the limit as X goes to zero it
is the same as the limit of the
derivatives and that's easy to evaluate
osai nub zero is one right this is equal
to five times the cosine of five x zero
and this is that's that's a
multiplication sign now maybe I should
just write this as zero divided by twice
the cosine of zero but you know that
that's five halves all right so this is
how l'hopital's method works it's a
pretty painless I'm going to give you
another example which shows that it
works a little better than the method
that I started out with here's what
happens if we consider the function
cosine X minus one divided by x squared
all right so that was a little harder to
deal with and again this is one of these
zero over zero things near x equals zero
as X tends to zero this goes to an
indeterminate form here now according to
our method this is this is equivalent to
now I'm going to use this little wiggle
because I don't want to write limit
limit limit limit limit million times so
I'm going to use a little wiggle here so
as X goes to zero this is going to
behave the same way as differentiating
numerator and denominator so again this
is going to be minus sine X
in the numerator the denominator it's
going to be 2x now notice that we still
haven't won yet because this is still of
0 over 0 type when you plug in x equals
0 you still get 0 but that doesn't
damage the method that doesn't make the
method fail this is 0 or 0 we can apply
l'hopital's rule a second time ok and as
X goes to 0 this is the same thing as
again differentiating the numerator and
denominator so here I get minus cosine X
in the numerator and I get 2 in the
denominator again this is way easier
than differentiating ratios of functions
we're only differentiating the numerator
and the denominator separately and now
it's it's this is the end as X goes to 0
this is minus cosine of 0 divided by 2
which is minus 1/2 and that's the right
now the justification for this comes
only when you win in the end and get the
limit because what the theorem says is
that if one of these limits exists then
the preceding one exists and once the
preceding one exists then the one before
it exists so once we know that this one
exists that works backwards it applies
to the preceding limit which then
applies to the to the very first one and
that the logical structure here is a
little subtle which is that if the right
side exists then the left side will also
exist yeah question
why does the right hand limit have to
exist isn't it just the derivative that
has to exist no the derivative of the
numerator has to exist the derivative of
the denominator has to exist and this
limit has to exist the what doesn't have
to exist by the way I've never said that
f prime of a has to exist in fact it's
much much more subtle I'm not claiming
that F prime of X is because in order to
evaluate this limit F prime of a need
not exist what has to happen is that
nearby for X not equal to a these things
exist and then the limit has to exist so
there's no requirement that the limits
exist in fact that's exactly the going
to be the point when we evaluate these
limits here is is we don't have to
evaluate it right at the end the right
hand we're living business opposed to
anywhere so the question that you're
asking is why is this the hypothesis of
the theorem in other words why does this
why does this work
well the answer is that this is a
theorem that's true if you drop this
hypothesis it's totally false and if you
don't have this hypothesis you can't use
the theorem and you will get the wrong
answer I mean it's hard to express it
any further than that so look in many
cases we tell you formulas and in many
cases it's so obvious when they're true
that we don't have to worry about what
we say all right and indeed there's
something implicit here I'm saying well
you know if I wrote this symbol down it
must mean that the thing exists so
that's a subtle point but what I'm
emphasizing is that you don't need to
know in advance that this one exists you
do need to know in advance that that one
exists you essentially yeah so that's
that's that's what it that's the
direction that it goes you you can't get
away with with not having this exist and
still have the statement be true all
right all right
yeah another question thank you it's
just that it's just that looks okay so
so I'm getting a little ahead of myself
but let me let me just say in these
situations here when X is going to 0 and
X is going to infinity for instance here
when X goes to 0 the logarithm is
undefined at x equals 0 nevertheless
this theorem applies and we'll be able
to use it over here as X goes to
infinity neither of these well actually
come to think of it e to the minus X if
you like it's equal to 0 at infinity if
you want to say that it has a value but
in fact you know these expressions don't
necessarily have values at the at the
ends and nevertheless the theorem
applies but you make you don't I mean it
can't exist it's perfectly okay for it
to exist it's no problem
it just doesn't need to exist doesn't
force to exist all right ok
all right so here's a calculation which
we just did and we evaluated this now I
want to make a comparison with the
method of approximation in the method of
approximations this example 2 which was
the example with the sine function would
be we would use the following property
we would use sine U is approximately u
we would use that linear approximation
and then what we would have here is that
sine of 5x divided by sine of 2x is
approximately 5 X divided by 2x which is
of course 5 halves and this is true when
u is approximately zero and this is true
certainly as X goes to 0 it's going to
be a valid limit all right so that's
very similar to
example two in example three we managed
to look at this expression cosine X
minus one divided by x squared and for
this one you have to remember the
approximation near x equals zero to two
the cosine function and that's 1 minus x
squared over 2 all right so that was the
approximation the quadratic
approximation to the cosine function and
now sure enough this simplifies this
becomes minus x squared over 2 divided
by x squared which is minus 1/2 so we
get the same answer which is a good
thing because both of these methods are
valid there they're consistent you can
see that that neither of them is
particularly a lot longer you may have
trouble remembering this property but in
fact it's it's something that you can
easily derive and indeed it's related to
the second derivative of the cosine as
is this calculation here they're almost
the same amount of numerical content to
them all right
so now what I'd like to do is is explain
to you why l'hopital's rule works better
in some cases and the real value that it
has is in handling these other more
exotic limits so let me just now we're
going to do the l'hopital's rule over
again and i'll handle these functions
but I'll have to rewrite them but we'll
just do that all right so here's the
property that the limit as X goes to a
of f of X divided by G of X is equal to
the limit as X goes to a of f prime of X
divided by G prime of X that's the
property and this is what we'll always
be using very convenient thing and it
remember it was true provide
that f of a is equal to G of a was equal
to zero and that the right hand side
exists all right but I claim that it
works better and I'll get rid of these
but I'll write them again to show you
that those it works for these so there
are other cases and the other cases that
are allowed are this first of all as
indicated by what I just erased you can
allow a to be equal to plus or minus
infinity it's also okay all right so you
can take the limit going to the far ends
of the universe both left and right and
then the other thing that you can do is
you can allow F of a and G of a to be
plus or minus infinity is okay all right
so now the point is that we can handle
not just the 0 over 0 case but also the
infinity over infinity case all right
that's a very powerful tool and quite
different from the other cases and the
third thing is that the right hand side
doesn't really quite have to exist in
the ordinary sense or it could be plus
or minus infinity that's also ok
that's still information so if we can
see where it goes then we're still good
all right if it goes to plus infinity if
it goes to 0 if it goes to a finite
number if it goes to minus infinity
all of that will be okay it's just if it
oscillates wildly that will be lost and
those calculations we'll never encounter
so this basically handles everything
that you could possibly hope for and
it's a very convenient process so let me
let me carry out a few examples and
let's see I guess the first one that I
wanted to do was X log X right
so what example are we up to example
three so example four is coming up
example four this is one of the ones
that I wrote at the beginning of the
lecture X log X this one was on a
homework problem in the in the limits of
some calculation but okay so this one
you have to look at it first to think
about what it's doing it's an
indeterminate form but it sort of looks
like it's the wrong type so why is it an
indeterminate form this one goes to zero
and this one goes to minus infinity so
excuse me this is a product it's 0 times
minus infinity so that's an
indeterminate form because we don't know
whether the 0 wins or the infinity wins
this could get getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and this getting
bigger and bigger and bigger the product
could be anything in between
you just don't know so the first step is
to write this as a ratio of things
rather than a product of things and it
turns out that the way to do that is to
use the logarithm in the numerator and
the 1 over x in the denominator so this
is a choice that I'm making here
now I've just converted it to a limit of
the type minus infinity divided by
infinity
because the numerator is going to minus
infinity as X goes to zero plus and the
denominator one over X is going to plus
infinity so again there's a competition
that now it's one of the forms to which
l'hopital's rule applies and now i'm
just going to apply l'hopital's rule and
what it says is that i differentiate
here so I just differentiated numerator
and denominator applying l'hopital's
rule is a breeze right you just
differentiate differentiate and now it
just simplifies and we're done this is
the limit as X goes to zero plus of well
the X Squared's cancel this is the same
as just minus X X sorry X factors cancel
and so that's zero the answer is that
it's zero right so X goes to zero faster
than log n goes to minus infinity this
zero was the winner something you can't
necessarily predict in advance all right
let's do the other two examples that I
wrote down I'm going to do them in
slightly more generality because they're
the most fundamental rate properties
that you're going to need to know for
the next section which is improper
integrals and also they're just very
important as for physical math and any
any other kind of thing basically so
here we'll let's just do these so let's
see which one do I want to do first so I
wrote down the limit of X e to the X e
to the minus X but I'm going to make it
even more general I'm going to make it
any negative power here where P is some
positive constant now again this is a
product of functions not a quotient a
ratio of functions and so I need to
rewrite it
and I'm going to write it as X divided
by e to the PS and now I'm going to
apply lock well so it's of this form
infinity over infinity okay okay with
that and now that's the same as the
limit as X goes to infinity of 1 divided
by PE to the PS so where does that go as
X goes to infinity now we can decide the
1 stays where it is and this as X goes
to infinity goes 2 goes to infinity all
right so the answer is 0 and the
conclusion is that X grows more slowly
then e to the PLS that's X goes to
infinity remember P is positive here of
course it's the increasing exponential
not the decreasing ones
all right let's do
a variant of this I'll do it the the
opposite way so this is I'm going to
call this example 5 Prime it really
doesn't give us any more information but
it gives you just a little bit more
practice so suppose I look at things the
other way X e to the PX / set X to the
100 power all right now this is an
infinity over infinity example again and
you can work out what it's doing but
there are two ways of thinking about
this
there's the slow way in the fast way the
slow way is to differentiate this a
hundred times that is right apply
l'hopital's rule over and over over over
again all the way down to now it's clear
that you could do it but it's kind of a
nuisance so there's a much cleverer
trick here which is to change this to
the limit as X goes to infinity of the e
to the power P X divided by 100 over X
to the hundredth power alright so if you
do that then we just have 1 l'hopital's
rule step here and that one is that this
is the same as as X goes to infinity of
well it's P over 100 e to the P x over
100 divided by 1 all to 100 of power all
right that's our l'hopital's step and of
course that's infinity over 102 the
100th power which is infinity now again
I did this in a slightly different way
to show you that it works with infinity
as well so that was this
case the right hand side can exist or it
can be plus or minus infinity and that
applies to this limit and therefore to
the original limit and the conclusion
here is that e to the P X P greater than
zero grows faster than any power of X I
picked X to the 100 that obviously
didn't matter what power I picked the
Exponential's beat all the powers all
right so we have one more of the ones
that I gave at the beginning to take
care of and that one is the logarithm
and it's behavior at infinity so I'll do
a slightly a slight variant on that one
too so we have example six which is log
X and I'm instead of dividing by X I'm
going to divide by X to the one-third I
could divide by any positive power of X
we'll just do this example here so now
this as X goes to infinity is of the
form infinity divided by infinity and so
it's equivalent to what happens when I
differentiate numerator and denominator
separately and that's 1 over X and here
I have 1/3 X to the minus 2/3 alright 1
over X and then 1/3 X to the minus 2/3
now when the dust settles here and you
get your exponents right we have an X to
the minus 1 and this is an X to the plus
2/3 and that's a 1/3 becomes a 3 so it's
this is what it is
alright and that's equal to 3x to the
minus 1/3
which we can decide it goes to zero as X
goes to infinity all right and so the
conclusion is that log X grows more
slowly as X goes to infinity then X to
the one-third or any positive power of X
okay so any X to the pp+
will work so log is really slow going to
infinity it's very very gradual yeah
question
the question is how many hypotheses do
you need here so I said that that and I
think what you were asking is if I have
this hypothesis can I can I also have
this hypothesis that's okay I can have
this hypothesis combined with this one
I need something about F of a and G of a
I can't assume nothing about F of a and
G of a so in other words I have to be
faced with either an infinity over
infinity or a zero over zero situation
so so let's see the rule applies and the
zero over zero or infinity over infinity
case these are the only two cases that
it applies in okay and X can be a can be
anything including infinity plus or
minus infinity okay the rule applies in
this in these two cases so in other
words this is the this is what F of a
over G of a is either one of these and
in fact it can be plus or minus and the
right hand side has to be something it
has to be either finite or plus or minus
infinity okay so you need something you
need a specific value of a you need to
decide whether it's an indeterminate
form and you need the right-hand limit
to exist
it's not hard to impose this there
because when you look at the right hand
side you'll want to be calculating it so
you'll want to know what it is so you'll
never never have problems confirming
this hypothesis okay all right I need to
well let me give you let me give you one
more example here which is just slightly
trickier which involves
so here's another indeterminate form
that's going to be zero to the zero
power so I mean there are lots of these
things where you just don't know what to
do and they come out in various
different ways the simplest example of
this is the limit as X goes to zero from
above of X to the X right now in order
to to work out what's happening with
this one we have to use a trick and the
trick is that this is a moving exponent
and so it's appropriate to use base e
this is something that we did way back
in the first unit so since this we have
a moving exponent we're going to use
base e that's the good base to use
whenever you have a moving exponent and
so we rewrite this as X to the X is
equal to e to the X log X and now in
order to figure out what's happening we
really only have to know what's going on
with the exponent all right so remember
actually we already did this but I'm
going to do it once more for you this is
log X over 1 over X and that's
equivalent as X goes to 0 2 using
l'hopital's rule to 1 over X and this is
minus 1 over x squared which is minus X
which goes to 0 as X goes to 0 and so
what we have here is that this one is
going to be equivalent to well it's
going to tend to what we got over here
it's e to the 0 right that exponent
is what we want as X goes to C all right
so that's the answer this limit happens
to be one it's actually relatively easy
to do given all the power that we have
in our hands now all right now let me
give you one more example suppose you're
trying to understand the limit of sine x
over x squared if you apply l'hopital's
rule as X goes to 0 you're going to get
cosine x over 2 X and if you apply
l'hopital's rule again as X goes to 0
you're going to get minus sine x over 2
and this as X goes to 0 goes to 0 right
on the other hand if you look at the
linear approximation method the linear
approximation says that sine X is
approximately X near 0 all right so that
should be x over x squared which is 1
over X which goes to infinity as X goes
to 0 at least from one side minus
infinity the other side so there's
something fishy going on here all right
this is fishy or maybe this is fishy I
don't know so tell me what what what's
wrong here
yeah your second little bit all wasn't
applied correctly because cosine X over
2x isn't in the trailer as X goes to 0
because cosine X is just warm ok all
right so the statement that the claim is
that the second application of
l'hopital's rule this one is wrong ok
and that's correct and this is where you
have to watch out with l'hopital's rule
this is exactly where you have to flush
out you have to apply the test here it's
an indeterminate form it's 0 over 0
before I applied the rule but in order
to apply the rule the second time it
still has to be 0 over 0 but this one
isn't this one is 1 over 0 alright it's
no longer an indeterminate form it's
actually infinite either plus or minus
depending on the sign of the denominator
which is just what this answer is so so
the linear approximation is safe and we
just applied l'hopital's rule wrong
alright so the moral of the story here
is look before you
ah all right now
let me just say one more thing I need to
pile it on just a little bit sorry III
don't so so don't don't use don't use it
as a crutch okay that's right we don't
want to just get ourselves so weak after
being in the hospital for all this time
that we can't use I'm sorry
so remember remember that you shouldn't
have lost your senses if you have
something like this so we'll do this one
here all right suppose you're trying to
understand what this does as X goes to
infinity now you could apply l'hopital's
rule five times or four times and get
the answer here all right but really you
should realize that the main terms are
sitting there right in front of you and
that there's some algebra that you can
do to simplify this namely it's the same
as 1 plus 2 over X plus 1 over X to the
fifth power all right and then in a
denominator well let's see it's X so
this would be dividing by 1 over X to
the fifth in both numerator and
denominator and here you have 1 over X
plus 2 over sorry I overshot but that's
ok 2 over X to the fifth here so these
are the main terms if you like and it's
the same as 1 over 1 over X which is the
same as X and it goes to infinity as X
goes to infinity or if you like much
more simply just X to the fifth over X
to the fourth is the main term which is
X which goes to infinity so don't forget
your basic algebra when you're when
you're doing this kind of stuff use
these things and don't use l'hopital's
rule okay see you next time